♪ ♪
A FAKE MISSILE ALERT AND SCARED
THE CRAP OUT OF EVERYBODY, WHERE
THE HELL WAS THERE GOVERNOR.
EVEN THOUGH DAVID EGAN KNEW IT
WAS WRONG, HE DIDN'T TELL THE PB
WAS WRONG, HE DIDN'T TELL THE PI
WAS WRONG, HE DIDN'T TELL THE PC
FOR 17 LONG MINUTES.
SURE THEY HAD APPROVED STRICT
REASON FOR LEAVING EVERYONE IN A
PANIC.
FINALLY HE CONFESSED HE DIDN'T
HERE IS THE STATE GOVERNOR WHO
THINKS HE CAN ONLY COMMUNICATE
VIA TWITTER WHICH RAISES THE
QUESTION, IS THE STATE RUN BY
TEENAGERS?
IT'S WORSE.
RUN BY DEMOCRATS WHICH BASICALLY
ARE TEENAGERS WITH POWER.
THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS TO
COMMUNICATE BY.
THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED TV AND
RADIO.
THERE IS THE HANDY TELEPHONE.
BUT HE COULDN'T EVEN CALM A
PANIC WITHOUT HIS TWITTER
PASSWORD.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD'VE PUT IT ON A
POST-IT NOTE AND LEFT IT ON HIS
COMPUTER.
WE HAVE ALL FORGOTTEN PASSWORDS.
THAT'S WHY I KEEP MINE SIMPLE.
BUT YOU DON'T NEED A PASSWORD TO
STAND IN FRONT OF A CAMERA AND
REPEAT FALSE ALARM, GO BACK TO
BED.
APPARENTLY THE HAWAIIAN
TWICE ABOUT RIPPING TRUMP ABOUT
HIS TWEETS.
THEY SHOWED MY PASSWORD FOR ONE
SECOND.
NOBODY COULD READ IT.
IT SAID "I LOVE UNICORNS
TEENAGER TOO.
>> Dana: VEEP IS MORE
REALISTIC THAN THE WEST WING.
THIS WOULD'VE HAPPENED.
DON'T DISAVOW.
SPEAK >> Greg: I WATCHED
5 MINUTES OF "SCANDAL."
THIS IS SO STUPID.
>> Kimberly: YOU TOLD ME, YOU
WE
BASHING HAWAII.
THAT'S WHAT WERE HERE FOR.
IS IT WEIRD HE DECIDED THERE'S
ONLY ONE WAY.
CALL ANYBODY.
CALL THE PRESIDENT AND ASK HIM
TO DO IT.
>> Jesse: HE DIDN'T EMAIL HIS
PASSWORD TO HACKERS.
ALL THESE PEOPLE,
ANTHONY WEINER, HILLARY, THE
GOVERNOR OF HAWAII, NOT THE BEST
AND BRIGHTEST.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO WHAT JUAN
DOES.
JUAN HAS A TWITTER VALET.
A MINION WHO HELPS HIM WITH HIS
TWITTER.
WHY DOESN'T THE GOVERNOR HAVE
ONE?
>> Kimberly: LIKE GREG HAS A
WINE VALET.
WIND.
I SHOULD SHOW YOU A PICTURE.
SEEMS LIKE THIS STATE IS RUN BY
TEENAGERS.
>> Juan: WHY ARE YOU WHACKING
OUT OF MY WIFE.
WHY IS GREG GOING?
SOMEBODY MADE A MISTAKE.
THEY HAVE SAID THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE A TWO-PERSON TEAM.
ONE PERSON CAN'T MAKE A MISTAKE
THE OFFICIALS KNEW.
>> Juan: DON'T YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO FORGET THEIR PASSWORD?
>> Greg: WHY DO I NEED
TWITTER?
I AM A GOVERNOR.
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM, SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS HOW TO WORK OR DEVICE.
SITUATION.
EVERYBODY IS WORKING SATURDAY
MORNING.
>> Greg: THE GUY!
>> Kimberly: THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> Dana: IN THE STORY EARLIER,
THEY HAVE THE PASSWORD ON THE
POST-IT NOTE ON THE COMPUTER.
>> Greg: I MENTION THAT.
HE WENT SO FAST WITH YOUR
PASSWORD.
>> Kimberly: HERE IS THE
PROBLEM.
IN ANOTHER CITY.
SO I CALLED MY WIFE AND I SAID
ARE YOU TRYING TO USE MY
PASSWORD?
SHE SAID YES.
MAYBE SHE WAS SNOOPING ON YOU.